[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je n'atteins était un homme
extraordinaire père de famille
absolument fantastique pour ses enfants
c'est un papa poule et un mari aimant
c'était voilà l'homme de ma vie quoi
la française nadège dubois 6 et son mari
johnatan ont vécu ensemble pendant 25
ans en février 2019
la famille passent des vacances de rêve
dans les alpes c'était vraiment des
moments inoubliables extraordinaire de
joie de bonheur c'était c'était juste
stabilisé alors que les enfants restent
en france
son conjoint planifier un déplacement au
kenya pour s'occuper de ces entreprises
hôtelières
ils achètent un billet sur ethiopian
airlines avec correspondance à addis
abeba plutôt qu'un vol direct
le 10 juin la table mais comment se
fait-il que tu es pris tu n'es pas pris
un billet direct et là il m'a rassuré
nancy joue les si cette campagne ici tu
l'excellente compagnie
les avions sont flambant neuf
le 10 mars dernier il monte donc à bord
du vol 302 ethiopian airlines faisant la
liaison addis abeba nairobi un court vol
de deux heures sur boeing 737 max
elle reçoit un appel inattendu d'un ami
de la famille vivant à neo
là je transmets phone pourrait je me
rappellerai toujours toute ma vie
c'était très dur la famille de mon mari
me dit non nadège oui bah oui j'étais
très surprise de l'entente mais bon je
fais outre il faut que tu sois très
forte justifie pourquoi mes enfants sont
autour de moi maman mais qu'est ce qui
se passe mais qu'est-ce qui se passe et
là je leur délivre la nouvelle sans
penser même que j'ai même pas je peux
pas réfléchir je dis mais mes enfants je
suis tellement désolée je suis tellement
désolée pour vous l'avion dans lequel
pas par et et s'est écrasé
157 personnes y compris 18 canadiens et
dix français périssent dans l'écrasement
du vol d'ethiopian airlines
q les détails commencent à émerger plus
les circonstances semblent étrangement
similaire à l'écrasement d'un appareil
de la nr survenue quatre mois auparavant
en indonésie également un 737 max
flambant neuf
derrière ces deux catastrophes les
décisions conséquences fatales d'un
géant américain devenu obnubilé par les
profits des documents internes dévoile
que boeing connaissait les lacunes de
l'appareil et montre à quel point
l'avionneur a influencé les autorités
réglementaires
dès son lancement en 2017
le nouveau 737 max devient rapidement
une poule aux oeufs d'or pour boeing
battant les records de vente et
propulsant géant américain devant son
rival européen airbus
brune en livres près de 400 et son
carnet de commandes est volumineux près
de 4000 appareils destinés à des dizaine
de transporteurs aériens y compris air
canada westjet et american airlines
american airlines s'apprête à passer une
commande très importante aux
compétiteurs airbus légende boeing
aurait dit non vous vous arrangez un
avion assez rapidement pour que vous
soyez 7 su alors course contre le temps
et c'est là où la culture économique
bien face à face avec la culture de la
sécurité
le mac c'est la dernière mouture du 737
dont le modèle original a été conçu en
1967 en raison de leur grande taille des
nouveaux moteurs plus performants prévu
pour la 737 max ont dû être installés
légèrement à l'avant et plus haut
une modification qui peut entraîner
l'avion à tanguy vers le haut
pour contrer cette tendance bouygues et
ajouté un logiciel appelé mks le système
d'augmentation de contrôle de manoeuvre
conçu pour pousser automatiquement le
lit de l'avion vers le bas afin d'éviter
un décrochage
nous avons évité deux pilotes de ligne à
la retraite le commandant denis germain
et le commandant jean lapointe à nous
rejoindre dans un simulateur de vol afin
de mieux comprendre ce que les pilotes
ont vécu lors de ces deux tragédies
le vol 610 de l'année un d'école de la
piste 25 l de l'aéroport de jakarta le
matin du 29 octobre 2018
il y à 189 personnes à bord mais dès le
décollage les pilotes sont confrontés à
des problèmes qui semblent alarmant
[Musique]
on attend de vibrateurs de contrôle 10
heures que l'avion est sur le point de
s'écraser t'es con d'un problème qui est
très grave parce qu'on sait pas si kevin
parce qu'on en a et puis on a ce brûleur
qui va perdurer pendant 13 minutes
durant le vol on va avoir des
indications de vitesse erronées du côté
gauche des indications à près d'une
minute de vol l'avion s'est incliné à
gauche selon le plan de vol prévu mais
une autre alarme se déclenche dans la
cabine suggérant que l'appareil tourne
trop brusquement
même si ce n'est pas le cas les bruits
inhabituels plusieurs lignes accent à
lui mais qui ne devrait même pas en live
en temps normal alors deux minutes et
une seconde après le décollage
vous avez un équipage de glee surchargé
ne sais pas ce qui se passe
une fois par mois
le commandant demande au copilote de
rentrer les volets au moment de la
rétraction des volets le système m15
entre en fonction croyant erronément que
l'avion est en décrochage en raison
d'une sonde défectueuse situé dans le
nez de l'avion le mks modifie l'angle de
la partie horizontale da que ce qui fait
brusquement piquer l'avion vers le bas
des pilotes sont pris par surprise par
un système dont ils ignorent totalement
l'existence
le commandant tire alors sur son manche
afin de faire remonter l'avion mais le
mk se réactive pendant 10 secondes et
refait plonger l'appareil
cette bataille terrifiante entre les
aime casser les pilotes se produit une
vingtaine de fois en quelques minutes un
combat inégal en raison de la puissance
du mks ses pilotes note comme les
membres d'équipage les passagers vont se
tenir jusqu'à des grâces
étant donné la grande vitesse de
l'appareil il devient impossible pour
les pilotes de reprendre le contrôle
avec les manivelles manuelle ou en
tirant sur le manche
[Musique]
vous êtes un être humain vous tenter de
retenir seulement celle à qui veut aller
vers l'avant et donc j'ai un moment
donné physiquement par là l'avion est
devenu plus puissant que la force
physique de 2 à être humain et la
biotech dans le sol on a placé les
membres d'équipage dans une position qui
les a menés dans être incapable de
garder le contrôle de la balle et sa
banane et ananas force
[Applaudissements]
m
les tout premiers indices mènent les
enquêteurs sur la piste du mks un
système dont boeing n'avait jamais
divulgué l'existence au pilote
auparavant une semaine après
l'écrasement de la rd1
la ffa à l'autorité réglementaire
américaine émet un bulletin d'urgence
elle informe les pilotes l'existence
d'un système de contrôle de vol qui
pourrait entraîner des difficultés à
contrôler l'avion ait un impact possible
avec le sol mais au lieu de clouer tous
les 737 max au sol la f1 se limite à
émettre des instructions aux pilotes
afin de désactiver le mk dans une
situation d'urgence similaires quelques
jours plus tard lors d'une réunion
privée avec des pilotes d'american
airlines boeing leur révèle plus de
détails au sujet de gm casse les pilotes
sont stupéfaits
cette réunion est enregistré
clandestinement par des pilotes
boeing leur indique avoir calculé
qu'advenant toute défaillance du mks
l'avionneur comptait sur les pilotes
pour sortir l'appareil du pétrin on a
répondu c'est une blague
je ne connais rien de ce système comment
voulez vous que je sois l'unique option
de secours
si je ne connais même pas son existence
le commandant denis stature d'american
airlines a assisté à cette rencontre
privée nous étions en colère
c'est très troublant pour des pilotes
d'apprendre qu'on n'aura pas transmis
l'information sur le système de sécurité
qui est critique d'aller installer un
système que les pilotes nous les pilotes
se soit 9,1 ils font voler ses environs
lors qu'on ne soit pas au courant c'est
impensable
on peut parler d'une trahison puis
d'avoir brisé le lien de confiance qui
si important dans le monde de l'aviation
un mois après l'écrasement de l'année en
décembre 2018
la f1 a effectué sa propre analyse pour
évaluer les risques liés au max tant que
les failles deuxième cas ce ne sont pas
rectifié la ffa estiment qu'ils
pourraient survenir plus d'une quinzaine
d'écrasement sur la durée de vie de la
flotte de 737 max causant près de 3000
décès en dépit de ces statistiques
alarmantes garder secrète la ffa a
choisi de maintenir les mac s'envole
estimant que les instructions aux
pilotes seront suffisantes
comment peut-on ignorer des informations
capitales comme ça c'est mettre la vie
des gens en danger la vie d'autrui
s'il avait pris les bonnes décisions
dont marie serait il sera encore long
les pilotes du vol 305 d'ethiopian
airlines était donc au courant de
l'existence du mks et de la procédure à
suivre
mais boeing n'avait pas informé que le
mk c'était si agressif et qu'il n'aurait
que quelques secondes pour réagir
boeing dans ces informations là qu'ils
ont donné à la communauté des pilotes
professionnels
c'était toujours du bout des lèvres même
si on avait la théorie on n'avait pas
exposé ses pilotes lors à la réalité de
la puissance du mkc beau des
informations théoriques mais vous voilez
pas un livre vous voilez un avion le 10
mars 2019
l'avion d'ethiopian décolle de
l'aéroport d'addis abeba à 17h38
une fois plus une sonde défectueuse
déclenché des alertes de vitesse et
d'altitude dans la cabine de pilotage
lorsque les voiles et sont rétractés
hennequin se déclenche et comme cela
s'est produit avec la haine et 1
l'avion commence à plonger si on dit que
le symbole de cette des montagnes russes
alors j'imagine ce que ça peut être sur
le monde est assis en arrière de l'avion
et que tout d'un coup c'est que le
stabilisateur change de quelques degrés
selon est terrifiée
les pilotes suivent les instructions
manipulant deux interrupteurs pour
désactiver le mkc mais l'avion vole déjà
à grande vitesse et se retrouve en
pleine plongée impossibles à corriger
[Musique]
à
six minutes seulement après le décollage
le 737max éthiopienne s'est écrasé dans
un champ à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres au sud-est de l'aéroport il a
touché sol à 8 185 km alors quand j'ai
su que l'avion s'est écrasé six minutes
après avoir décollé et là franchement
y'a pas photo je savait d'emblée enfin
après toutes les informations que nous
avons reçues que c'était pas juste une
erreur de pilotage
un peu facile de mettre tout cela sur le
dos des pilotes un combat entre
gonyalons
dans lequel je m'engage et que je
n'arrêterai pas que lorsque j sera fans
deux mois après l'écrasement nadège
dubois 6 convoque les médias paris et
annonce qu'elle poursuit boeing après le
crash de liner il sait tout le monde
était parfaitement au courant
cet avion n'aurait jamais dû décoller
c'est quelque chose c'est un accident
qui aurait pu être évitée on prend pas
des chances avec des vignerons à ces
criminels ces criminels ils ont tué mon
mari
moment tous à cheval c'est un petit peu
ma bouée de secours ou quand ça à part
hommes
monter à cheval est devenu en quelque
sorte la thérapie de nadège dubois 6 la
douleur est encore vive depuis que son
mari johnatan est mort dans l'écrasement
d'un boeing 737 max en ethiopie en mars
dernier chic ou une fois j'ai appelé son
numéro téléphone en me disant mais
peut-être que c'est une mauvaise blague
j'aime réveiller de ce cauchemar est
bien conscient non non c'est pas
possible il va jamais répondre ce que
c'est c'est la réalité c'est il va
parcourir
depuis l'écrasement
nadège chercheurs obtenir justice et
suit attentivement d audience du congrès
américain au sujet du 737 max
en octobre dernier le directeur général
de boeing dennis muilenburg a été appelé
à comparaître
qu'il dise once was never had et mks
femmes be proud
[Musique]
mais il s'avère que brink's avait déjà à
l'époque presque tous que l'avionneur
s'est aujourd'hui permis des documents
internes de boeing obtenu par le comité
du congrès il y à cette note de service
de 2015 trois ans avant le premier
écrasement des ingénieurs de boeing au
nautic le 737max étaient vulnérables aux
défaillances de sonde avec le m casque
un autre document interne de boeing
montre qu'en juin 2010 8,4 mois avant le
premier écrasement boeing c'est avec les
pilotes n'auraient que quatre secondes
pour reconnaître un raté du mks et
seulement 10 secondes pour le corriger
et pour éviter la catastrophe un
journaliste du seattle times dominique
gates a fait enquête
je ne suis pas surpris que des
ingénieurs et émis des inquiétudes liées
à la sécurité
ils ont dit mais qu'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire ici ce qui est incroyable
c'est que ces questions sont demeurées
sans réponse et ce design s'est faufilé
malgré tous ses défauts le matériel de
marketing du boeing 737 max soulignait
qu' aucune formation en simulateur de
vol ne serait nécessaire pour les
pilotes déjà formés sur l'ancien modèle
nous voulons
nouveau 737 qui est comme l'ancien nous
ne voulons pas que nos pilotes suivent
une formation coûteuse win a donc promis
à sa triste que leur souhait serait
exaucé
sinon l'avionneur s'engage à leur verser
un million de dollars par appareil
ça montre à quel point c'était important
pour boeing boeing assurait les
transporteurs aériens qu'une simple
formation sur un ipad serait suffisante
un ehpad qu'on pouvait faire un faisant
son jogging ya peut-être d'autres
pilotes qu'ils en regardant faisant la
vaisselle ou kino regard des 25 minutes
comme n'y avait pas d'examen public se
terrant dans c'était vraiment
élémentaire est clairement insuffisant
et afin d'éviter qu'une formation plus
onéreux soit imposée aux transporteurs
aériens
pauline a même retiré la description du
mks du manuel à l'intention des pilotes
selon le courriel interne obtenu par le
congrès américain
pourtant dennis molenbeek a insisté à
maintes reprises que la sécurité était
primordiale chez boeing
[Musique]
boeing jouissait d'une excellente
réputation en matière de sécurité par le
passé mais les choses ont commencé à
changer après sa fusion avec l'avionneur
mac dans leur graisse en 1997 le
physicien stan torture et l'ingénieur
cynthia qu étaient des employés de
longue date de boeing les cadres de mecs
dans l'autobus était plus impitoyable il
de penser qu'au bénéfice net et comment
ça brille dans l'icône leur profil est
plus important selon ce modèle
d'affaires personne ne dit jamais non
on suit les directives c'est le modèle
de gestion n'ont pas adhéré un bon
modèle capitaliste ils ont été motivées
par la cupidité les intérêts des cadres
supérieurs et mais surtout
ces propos sont confirmés par des
courriels et des clavardages internes
d'employés de boeing que vient d'obtenir
le congrès américain pourquoi
soumissionnaire le moins réputés at il
reçu le contrat uniquement parce que
c'était lé moins cher écrit un employé
l'avion était conçu par des clowns et
supervisées par des singes écrit un
autre
c'est un article qui date de quand de ce
matin c'est fort
l'avion était design et par des clowns
ont supervisé par les sages nadège a
formé une association pour les familles
des victimes françaises de concert avec
virginie fricot des qui a perdu son
frère dans l'écrasement du vol
d'ethiopian airlines
mais tu vois tout le temps tout en
couper les coûts au niveau des
fournisseurs au niveau 2 à tout point de
vue quoi pas de training pas ça coûte
trop cher à ces essais c'est une logique
tellement tellement actuel tellement une
logique tellement de notre monde la
réduction des coûts
la productivité à outrance dans des
courriels internes
le pilote en chef de boeing s'est même
vanté d'avoir réussi à manipuler la
pensée des autorités réglementaires afin
dé convaincre qu'une formation en
simulateur de vol n'était pas nécessaire
c'est là féroé via son administration de
la f1 sur qui repose la responsabilité
de certifier le 737max pendant son
processus de conception et de
fabrication
mais une grande partie de cette
surveillance a été sous traité à des
salariés de boeing en raison du manque
d'expertisé l' effort et afin de réduire
les coûts ça me choque profondément que
quelques constructeurs puissent auto
certifié hotoveli des assassins son
design c'est aberrant serviront leïla ne
s'occupaient que de la paperasse al
interne des gens voulaient conserver une
part plus importante du travail de
certification technique des
gestionnaires de l'aef à leur ont dit
non ça va gêner boeing japan ce que ces
deux accidents alors vont être un
tournant important dans le monde de
l'aviation sur comment les avions aussi
seront certifiés dans le futur et de
laisser certifie les nouveaux avions que
par le bio nerfs et un gestionnaire
ça ne se fera peut-être plus jamais le
sénateur américain richard blumenthal
croit lui aussi que cette façon de faire
doit changer de système et broc
le système est déficient la culture de
la f1 doit changer
ils doivent cesser de déléguer leur
autorité et mettre fin à un système qui
met le loup dans la bergerie
mais lors d'audiences en décembre
dernier le directeur de la ffa a admis
et que le système de supervision
d'industrie était défaillante
boeing vient de suspendre temporairement
la production du 737 max et l'avionneur
vient finalement d'accepter qu'une
formation en simulateurs de vols
deviennent obligatoires
une enquête du département américain de
la justice est en cours au sujet de
l'interaction de boeing avec le f à des
dirigeants de boeing seront ils tenus
responsables non ces cadres supérieurs
sont trop étroitement liés les uns aux
autres ils ne se retourneront pas contre
l'un des leurs mais des gens sont des
gens qui ont des familles et dont les
vies ont été écourtés ici boeing [ __ ]
millions $ d'amande
je ne sais quoi oui la justice
le directeur général de nice bornes bug
a été congédié le mois dernier mais il
quitte avec des options d'achat
d'actions et une retraite dorée d'une
valeur de 62 millions $ américaine le
directeur général qu'il remplace affirme
que boeing avait mal évalué comment des
pilotes réagirait en cas de problème et
il n'y que l'avionneur et délibérément
décidé de maximiser les profits aux
dépens de la sécurité
je sais pas comment monsieur moulin
bague ou nouveaux sillons mis en place
maintenant dormir mais à ce jour je n'ai
reçu aucune lettre d' excuses de la part
de boeing à temps tout doit être changée
à tous les niveaux si c'est mon combat
pour jeunes à table pour mes enfants
pour moi même et pour que personne ne
vivent ce qu'on a vécu
je ne le souhaite à personne bisous à
papa
[Musique]
c'est ça qui est très dur c'est se faire
à l'idée qu'il ne reviendra plus et
c'est de vivre de continuer à vivre sans
lui
avec toi
[Musique]
avec toutes les mémoires de mes
souvenirs
[Musique]
je